Навпроти мене Ігор Коломойський, український бізнесмен
і глава обласної адміністрації Дніпропетровська
та Дніпропетровської області  в 2014-2015 роках.
Ігорю Валерійовичу, спасибі вам за інтерв‘ю.
Ми з вами перебуваємо зараз у Женеві. Коли ви востаннє були в Україні?
У червні минулого року.
Чому так довго вже не їздите?
Якщо ви чули, у нас є певні судові процеси з "Приватбанком",
і у зв‘язку з особливостями законодавства України
є ймовірність того, що якщо я приїду, то не зможу звідти виїхати.
Не в тому сенсі, що мене кудись посадять або зачинять,
а з точки зору, що є, припустімо, претензії "Приватбанку" до мене
і на основі цих матеріальних претензій можна у нас закрити виїзд,
можуть оголосити тебе боржником і закрити виїзд з України.
А враховуючи, що судові процеси наші відбуваються не лише в Україні,
але ще й у Лондоні, то, відповідно, займатися усіма цими питаннями,
працюючи з адвокатами, простіше, перебуваючи в Європі,
ніж, скажімо, як невиїзний з України.
Вас у 2014 році, в розпал
таких драматичних подій в Україні,
призначили головою адміністрації Дніпропетровської області.
І ви вже в інтерв'ю пізніше, після відставки, сказали таке -
я хочу це процитувати:
"Гординя - смертний гріх, але я пишаюся.
Для мене це - великий подвиг"
Могли б ви розповісти, в чому полягав ваш подвиг і чим ви, власне, пишаєтеся?
Ну, у кожної людини своя система оцінки цінностей, своє мірило.
І мені здалося, що для мене тоді,
людини, яка мешкає взагалі-то в Європі, в Женеві, в комфортних умовах,
взяти все кинути і поїхати в Україну, виконувати свій ...
Тобто, це було саме так, ви не перебували в Україні?
Ні, я перебував у Женеві, звичайно.
Я в Женеві перебуваю давно,
тому не можна сказати, що я мешкаю в Україні і приїжджаю в Женеву.
Я живу в Женеві й іноді приїздив в Україну.
Тоді я все кинув і переїхав в Україну,
вступив на державну посаду і взагалі-то виконав свій громадянський обов'язок.
Ні, ви зараз говорите про те, що ви вийшли із зони комфорту
і приїхали із Женеви до Дніпропетровська.
Але в чому полягав ваш подвиг,
крім того, що ви вийшли зі своєї зони комфорту?
Ну, я вважаю, що це був вчинок.
Перш за все - вже вийти із зони комфорту.
Загалом, не порахуватися з думкою, скажімо так, тут живе вся моя сім'я,
батьки, сестра, діти, дружина,
і я якось не дуже з ними радився, зробив цей вчинок.
Цим я вже пишаюся.
Ну, а з тим, що відбувалося далі, вже цю оцінку можуть давати всі інші.
Ми з вами про це поговоримо докладніше.
Але спочатку я хочу процитувати ту оцінку, яку дав Володимир Путін вашому вчинку,
вашому подвигу, як ви кажете.
Він досить нервово відреагував на ваше призначення і сказав, я знову процитую:
"Це - унікальний пройдисвіт, він навіть нашого олігарха Абрамовича обдурив"
З чим пов'язана така оцінка вашої особистості
з боку Володимира Путіна?
І про що взагалі йдеться, коли він казав цю фразу?
Ну, Володимир Володимирович на рік тоді вже запізнився в оцінці,
тому що ми за рік ...
у нас був судовий процес, арбітражний процес
з компанією,  в якій Абрамович є акціонером,
це було пов'язано з угодою, пов'язаною з «Євразом»,
ще 2007 року,
а потім, з 2009-го або 2010-го до 2013-го
був арбітражний процес, в якому одна сторона була позивачем,
інша, моя сторона - відповідачем.
І ми довго судилися, а потім підписали мирову угоду.
Без подробиць, тому що це - конфіденційно.
Тобто ми розійшлися миром ще за рік до того,
як Володимир Володимирович давав цю оцінку.
А з чим ви пов'язуєте те, що він вирішив прокоментувати ваше призначення?
Тобто у нього якась особиста до вас неприязнь?
Ну, в той момент точно була. Я ж за добу до цього дав коментар під час мого призначення...
Я, власне, хотіла спитати. Ви назвали Володимира Путіна шизофреніком.
Це було на прес-конференції у Дніпропетровську
3 березня 2014 року:
"який зовсім у повному неадекваті"
Ви зараз дотримуєтеся тієї ж точки зору? Чи щось змінилося?
Ну, скажімо так, вже перебуваючи на посаді губернатора,
я мав би, по ідеї, добирати слова.
Однак що стосується емоцій,
я вважаю те, що сталося між Україною і Росією,
події в Криму і те, що зараз триває на Донбасі,
хоча тоді ще на початку березня 2014-го все це було невідомо.
Ще 10 тисяч або 20 тисяч осіб були живі,
ще не було мільйона біженців.
Але, в принципі, вже тоді було видно, до чого це може призвести.
Ну, можете знайти інший вислів.
Який?
Можете назвати це не «шизофренією»,
а «божевіллям». Може, ще якийсь.
Хоча йшлося ж не лише про нього
Йшлося про Януковича насамперед. Через якого все це сталося.
Скажімо так, вираз емоційний, але, за великим рахунком, за формою, так,
може, я уже і не мав права на цій посаді це казати...
Але, по суті,... так, це було відразу після призначення.
Так-так-так.
Я приїхав прямо на призначення на посаду.
Недипломатичний вираз був.
Але ж ви відомі своїми недипломатичними виразами, чи не так?
Ну, може бути. Може, тут треба було ...
якщо це викликало таку бурхливу реакцію іншого боку...
Знаєте, буває «не нашкодь», так?
З одного боку.
Ну, якщо мої слова посилили конфлікт ... це було неправильно.
Але з іншого боку, була така ситуація,
була обстановка, а найголовніше, були люди навколо, які в принципі,
думали, вважали так само, як і я.
І я, вступаючи на цю посаду,
повинен був показати і показав, що ми перебуваємо на одному боці барикад.
І однаково оцінюємо те, що відбувається.
Скажіть, будь ласка, ось все-таки я повернуся до вашої фрази.
Мовляв, те, що ви зробили, ставши губернатором Дніпропетровської області
- це подвиг.
Чи можете ви сказати, що завдяки вам Дніпропетровська область
не стала ціллю сепаратистів, і ви уникли
або запобігли там такому повномасштабному конфлікту,
який стався в Донецькій і Луганській областях?
Ну, вона була ціллю,
такою ж ціллю, як була й Донецька, Луганська або Одеська області.
Вона була ціллю.
Не лише мені, з моїми друзями, з моїми колегами, зі своєю командою вдалося цьому запобігти.
А як вам вдалося цьому запобігти?
Ну, коли ми говоримо про подвиг,
то я якраз, якщо посилатися на те інтерв'ю,
під подвигом мав на увазі вчинок, пов'язаний з переїздом.
Я зрозуміла. А як технічно вам вдалося, які кроки ви зробили конкретні,
які призвели до того, що Дніпропетровськ і Дніпропетровська область
не стали об'єктом або ціллю сепаратистів?
І цей регіон не перейшов під їхній контроль.
Ну, дивіться, коли я став губернатором, завдання не стояло...
Не стояло питання, що треба зробити сьогодні конкретні якісь дії.
І це нас врятує від якихось проблем.
Тому ми приступили до роботи,
вивчили обстановку,
подивилися загрози, подумали, як ми можемо їх парирувати.
Загроз було багато.
Не забувайте, що все це було під натиском і під можливістю,
небезпеки зовнішнього вторгнення.
Тобто, є величезна кількість обов'язків,
які повинен робити керівник обласної адміністрації.
Пов'язані з мобілізаційним планом,
із не дай бог, військовими діями, з мобілізацією, з комплектацією, з допомогою армії.
Ну, і коли ми розібрали зі всім,
то ми побачили, що все перебуває в досить сумному стані.
І довелося робити досить великі зусилля для того, щоб...
Знаєте, була проблема внутрішня, пов'язана з "п'ятою колоною"
і з конфліктом, який розпалювався,
кий вдалося запалити в Донецьку і в Луганську
і не вдалося запалити в інших...
"П'ята колона", могли б Ви конкретизувати, про яких людей ідеться?
Ну, перш за все, в Дніпропетровську це був ... головний лідер - це Царьов.
Він очолював цю "п'яту колону", на ньому замикалося все...
Кому він підпорядковувався у свою чергу?
Ну, я не пам»ятаю, там, у Москві... Глазьєв. Ось ця команда була.
Вже чотири роки минуло...
Це внутрішнє, а ще що?
Ну, це була серйозна проблема, тому, що він
був пов'язаний з усілякими громадськими організаціями,
він був легітимний народний депутат України.
Він був чоловік - досить багатий. Він користувався авторитетом.
У нього були власні охоронні структури.
Він міг і намагався зробити багато проблем.
Як ви змогли це нейтралізувати?
Ну, ми з ним тривалий час розмовляли, проводили виховну роботу.
Але потім, коли було зрозуміло, що нічого не виходить,
якось так ми з ним домовилися, що він поїхав до Москви.
Точніше, він був якийсь час ще в Донецьку.
Потім він поїхав до Москви.
Але це вже було наприкінці. Коли вже всі ці загрози стали, скажімо так, сходити нанівець.
Ну, зовнішні загрози. Була весь час небезпека зовнішньої агресії.
Тобто, після подій у Криму ми розуміли, що може бути ...
Нам кожен раз казали про те, що завтра, післязавтра, такого-то числа
ми повинні бути приведені в бойову готовність.
Ну і, розумієте, у нас було командування Південної групи військ.
Ми були в прифронтовій смузі і, загалом, в Дніпрі
тоді сходилася вся логістика...
Це був логістичний вузол. Для можливого Опору в разі агресії.
Ну, відповідно, ми повинні були проводити всі заходи, що були передбачені мобілізаційним планом.
І треба було робити якісь дії, які не прописані в жодних планах.
Починаючи від того, що, припустімо, вся армія має бути забезпеченою
і на складах повинно бути пальне й акумулятори.
Боєприпаси. А чогось там не було...
Українська армія не була готова до такого розвитку ситуації?
Сама країна не була готова до того, що буде війна.
За повідомленнями ЗМІ, ви фінансували добровольчі батальйони.
Чи так це?
Ну, це був наступний етап.
Розкажіть. Як вони формувалися? Який обсяг фінансування?
Добровольчі батальйони були пов'язані...
там були дві причини появи добровольчих батальйонів.
Перша причина - батальйони були різні.
Тобто, були батальйони територіальної оборони, які приписувалися міністерству оборони,
це був другий етап створення таких батальйонів.
І це було пов'язано насамперед зі, скажімо, не дуже вдалою мобілізаційною політикою.
Тобто, коли оголосили хвилю мобілізації:
першу, другу, третю. Коли не всі
готові були добровільно йти в армію.
Ну і, загалом, проводилася роз'яснювальна робота.
Скажімо так, пропагандистська в якійсь мірі робота.
І ті люди, які були найбільш активними ,
хоча може, вже і не були зобов»язані йти в армію...
Тобто, що таке добровольці?
Це ті, хто не зобов'язаний іти, але йшов.
А на тлі того, що було багато тих, хто був зобов'язаний, але не йшов...
Загалом ті, хто був не зобов'язаний і йшов, вони хотіли служити в добровольчих батальйонах.
Тобто, вони хотіли, щоб ці батальйони були сформовані виключно з добровольців.
Тому з'явилися так звані добровольчі батальйони.
Мушу вам сказати, що вони все одно
були не на сто відсотків з добровольців, все одно був змішаний склад.
Тобто, батальйони територіальної оборони формувалися
під егідою Міністерства оборони.
Друга частина - це були батальйони патрульно-постової служби,
які формувалися під егідою і підпорядковувалися Міністерству внутрішніх справ.
А потім вони перейшли у підпорядкування,
наскільки я знаю, Національної гвардії України.
Це на кшталт внутрішніх військ.
Це були батальйони патрульно-постової служби.
Мені здається, один з перших був - «Дніпро-1».
Який був створений у Дніпропетровську.
Вони формувалися в основному з активістів, учасників Майдану,
ось цих добровольчих сотень.
Яким було, за великим рахунком, нічим зайнятися.
Точніше, їм було чим зайнятися,
але вони не знали, як це робити.
Тобто, наведенням ладу на вулицях, боротьбою зі злочинністю, з бандитизмом.
Що сталося? У нас, у зв'язку з подіями на Майдані в Києві,
чинна система внутрішніх справ була зруйнована.
Як ви розумієте, вона була на боці попереднього режиму Януковича.
Відповідно, всі внутрішні війська, «Беркут»,
Національної гвардії тоді не було…. «Беркут»,
внутрішні війська, патрульно-постова служба, вони були під управлінням
колишнього керівництва Міністерства внутрішніх справ.
Природно, після перемоги революційних сил на Майдані
вони перебували в розладнаному стані,
деморалізованому.
Вони повинні були прийти до тями...
над ними висіла загроза кримінальних переслідувань за ті події,
які відбувалися на Майдані,
і за зловживання, які були, ймовірно, вчинені.
Тому в нас не було , скажімо, Міністерства внутрішніх справ.
Воно тільки починало формуватися заново.
Це ясно ... А скільки це було людей
і скільки грошей ви витратили на те, щоб фінансувати ці добровольчі батальйони?
Ну, щодо патрульно-постової служби, по-моєму,
був один або два батальйони.
«Дніпро-1», не пам'ятаю, «Дніпро-2» були під егідою МВС.
А те, що стосується територіальної оборони,  то ми брали участь...
щонайменше, лише на території Дніпропетровської області
у створенні мінімум... п'яти або шести батальйонів.
А в доларах можете сказати, скільки це коштувало все?
Ну, мені важко сьогодні судити, скільки це коштує.
Для того, аби сформувати батальйон, на першому етапі не потрібні гроші.
ому що більше потрібні комплектація, озброєння, бронежилети,
взуття, форма і найголовніше - озброєння.
Ну, наскільки я розумію, ті батальйони, які були ППС -
патрульно-постової служби, вони були озброєні легкою зброєю.
Там була тільки стрілецька зброя в основному.
А потім їх уже переформували в полк.
Коли вони потрапили в Національну гвардію,
по-моєму, їх забезпечили вже важким озброєнням.
Але це було вже, по-моєму, в 2015-16 році.
Що стосується отих батальйонів Міністерства оборони, то їх формували.
Вони одразу йшли на фронт, а ми продовжували їх підтримувати,
тобто курирувати ці батальйони.
На фронт, на лінію зіткнення, яка утворилася,
а  також туди, куди їх посилало Міністерство оборони,
тут я не можу сказати.
Деякі люди, які спостерігали за добровольчими батальойнами,
у формуванні яких ви брали активну участь,
вони казали, що там були такі
націоналістичні люди, націоналістично налаштовані.
З огляду на ваше походження, очевидно, що вам, напевно,
не близькі такі ультранаціоналісти, які є в Україні?
Можу помилятися. Не було у вас якогось протиріччя,
що ви підтримуєте тих людей, чиї ідеї повинні бути вам чужими?
Ну, питання, звичайно, як то кажуть, цікаве.
Але ви змішали два поняття в одному питанні:
націоналістичні настрої і ультранаціоналістичні.
Я про ультранаціоналистичні кажу.
Те, що ультранаціоналістичних настроїв було небагато,
практично їх не було і ми їх не помічали, не бачили.
Ну, звісно, ми їх не поділяли. Більше того,
одна зі, скажімо так, функцій мого призначення
або піар-функція мого призначення полягала в тому,
що коли єврея поставили губернатором на тлі розмов про те,
що прийдуть бандерівці і почнуть єврейські погроми,
це заспокоювало, в тому числі,
й досить велику єврейську громаду Дніпропетровська
або Дніпропетровської області, Кривий Ріг,
Новомосковськ, Дніпродзержинськ, Павлоград.
Тому ні про який антисемітизм або якихось ультранаціоналістів
Хоча націоналізм, з вашого висловлювання, звучить досить негативно.
Я мала на увазі ультранаціоналізм.
З точки зору зовнішньої агресії з боку Російської Федерації
то націоналізм це - позитивне явище.
Тобто, не було б націоналізму, Україна вже приєдналася б до Росії.
Вже забули б про це.
Вже в 2014 році була б нова якась Переяславська рада.
Ось, я багато разів ставила багатьом українським політикам
або тим людям, які займаються врегулюванням конфлікту на  Донбасі,
одне й те саме запитання:
Що відбувається на Донбасі, як ви можете це охарактеризувати?
Це громадянська війна чи, як ви кажете, громадянський конфлікт,
чи все-таки це - агресія з боку Росії?
Чи це якась гібридна, проміжна форма?
Що там відбувається?
Ну, я намагався знайти аналогії в історії,
в попередній історії людства.
Які були конфлікти, на що це схоже?
Що найбільше мені підходило для порівняння це -
громадянська війна в Іспанії.
Хоча, якщо в Іспанії була громадянська війна,
то я б назвав те, що відбувається на Донбасі -
заколот, інспірований зовнішньою стороною
В даному разі - Російською Федерацією,
яка повністю забезпечила важким, легким і іншим озброєнням,
інспірувала, провокувала і потурає цьому заколоту
І намагалася цей заколот підняти
не лише в Донецьку і Луганську, але й на території інших областей:
в Одесі, Дніпропетровську, Запоріжжі, Харкові
Ось і вийшло тільки в Донецьку у них і в Луганську
Тому цей заколот був інспірований
і створений Росією
Але сьогодні я можу називати його сміливо громадянським конфліктом
тільки за однією характерною ознакою
тому що з обох сторін
брали участь громадяни України
Так, з одного боку повністю він підтримується Російською Федерацією
забезпечується зброєю,
військовими інструкторами
командним складом, боєприпасами,
матеріально-технічним постачанням
кордон відкритий, жодної проблеми з цим немає
З точки зору постачання, вони не відчувають
це не те, що до Іспанії кораблі відвозити
або до Сирії сьогодні щось доставляти
Російська Федерація повністю підтримувала
З іншого боку, вона, може, вже десь хотіла б
завершити всю цю історію і звалити звідти
Ви так вважаєте?
Тому що занадто висока ціна за це, так
Ну, є безліч проблем, чому вона це не може зробити
А розкажіть, будь ласка, це цікаво. Чому?
Чому? Ну, тому що, я гадаю, на першому етапі
з огляду на ідеологію Російської Федерації
з точки зору захисту російськомовного населення
основне питання, яке буде стояти,
яке буде наріжним каменем
А якою буде доля і яка гарантія для тих, хто брав участь у конфлікті з іншого боку?
Для тих, скажімо так, українських громадян, які були на боці незаконних збройних формувань,
всіх ДНРів, ЛНРів
Ну, всіх же до Москви не забереш?
І всіх до Росії не забереш?
І синів їх не забереш
Вони там не ходитимуть в цих «іспанках»
з цими бантіками випускними
Тобто, це основна причина?
Так. А як? Там чотири мільйони людей
Ну, якщо, припустімо, 100 тисяч, 200 тисяч людей
підтримали цей конфлікт, взяли в руки зброю
Як з ними бути? І сьогодні, припустімо, коли йдеться
про реінтеграцію Донбасу або про якісь речі,
пов'язані з амністією...
Ну, це все добре, але як розібратися,
хто брав у руки зброю?
У кого на руках кров? І хто буде розбиратися?
Думаю, що поки Росія і особисто Путін
не отримають відповіді на ці питання, в
вони не підуть з Донбасу
і цей конфлікт буде підтримуватися і тривати
Це питання ціни. Тобто, що буде дорожче для Росії
підтримувати це?
І як довго Україна зможе це терпіти?
Я хотіла дізнатися про те
як складаються зараз
ваші стосунки з Петром Порошенком
чи вважаєте ви його своїм опонентом?
Все-таки ви якийсь час не їздите в Україну
Я не хочу вдаватися в деталі усіляких бізнес-суперечок
навколо Приватбанку,
який націоналізували в 2016 році
Я так розумію, що зараз вже триває
пошук нових власників
за позовом держави у вас заморожені активи
Це було рішення лондонського суду
Друга суперечка пов'язана з Укрнафтою
Наскільки мені відомо, в кінці квітня
ви програли в суді Нафтогазу
Те, що відбувається, це політична гра,
з вашого погляду?
Чи все-таки у держави є обґрунтовані претензії
до бізнесу Приватбанку?
Вас звинувачують у виведенні активів і так далі
І до того, що відбувалося з Укрнафтою
Ну, перше
Не будемо ототожнювати пана Порошенка
незважаючи на те, що він
чинний президент України
з державою Україна
Тим більше, менше ніж за рік
до президентських виборів
Так, він чинний президент України
Але це не означає, що є претензії у держави до нас як колишніх власників
Добре, а у кого є претензії?
Вони є у Порошенка і є вони
абсолютно з інших причин
з яких ви поставили запитання на самому початку
є він опонентом чи ні?
Можна, я хочу тоді уточнити
Все-таки лондонський суд, який ви дуже поважаєте
вирішив заарештувати активи ваші
Значить, вони їх ...
А чий позов?
Позов до держави,
яка є зараз власником Приватбанку
Ні. Позивач - Приватбанк
Приватбанк - це акціонерне товариство
Зовсім недавно акціями Приватбанку володіли
я і мій партнер Боголюбов, відсотків на 90
Наскільки я пам'ятаю
Потім відбулася незаконна,
з моєї точки зору, націоналізація
З приводу чого ведуться судові процеси в Україні
і ведуться вони, скажімо так, з перемінним успіхом
але більше, як на мене, на нашу користь
І я гадаю, коли в цих судових процесах буде поставлено крапку
я можу оптимістично дивитися в майбутнє
тому що вже ... ви ж знаєте, в Україні були не націоналізовані
а ліквідовані ще понад 80 банків
Щодо дуже багатьох з них
зараз ухвалили рішення про те
що це було все незаконно, інспіровано
і зроблено неправильно
Якщо це було неправильно, то тоді нам, по ідеї
треба повернути банк
І тоді весь лондонський процес
закінчиться сам по собі
тому що ми ж не можемо самі проти себе судитися
Тому на сьогоднішній день
поки контроль у держави над банком
вони інспірували один процес ще в Лондоні
Чітко з однією метою
якось ускладнити нам життя з нашими активами
Заморозити ці активи, ввести нам
обмеження з особистих витрат
Ну, поки є такий наказ суду, ми його виконуємо
такі правила гри
Але я-то знаю всі підводні камені
Тепер щодо Порошенка, опонент він чи ні
я вам розповім, у чому основні причини
Порошенко не може бути моїм опонентом
тому що ми з ним ніде не змагаємося у ніякій відкритій політичній боротьбі
Я не беру участь у президентських перегонах
і не збираюся брати участь
Я не є офіційно ніякої опозицією
хоча очолюю контрольно-ревізійний комітет
партії "Українське об'єднання патріотів"
Але, тим не менше, я не займаюся активною політичною діяльністю
Зокрема, може, через те, що не маю сьогодні можливості
Але з Порошенком я опонент
Опонент світоглядний
У чому це полягає?
Це полягає в нашому різному ставленні до життя
До демократії, до свободи слова, до подій в Україні
до ставлення до того, яким повинен бути президент
І які у нього повинні бути відносини
з власним народом
зі своєю країною
Ось в цьому ми з ним повністю відрізняємося
Тому ... у мене з приводу нього
дуже велике розчарування
Тому я є його опонентом. Але, знову ж таки
це наше внутрішнє питання
і наше з ним протистояння, опонентство
Воно зовсім не вимагає,
щоб мені хтось допомагав ззовні
І, скажімо так, це - внутрішня справа України
Наше з ним опонентство
Ви сказали про те, що ви не є
опонентом Петра Порошенка
бо ви відкрито не берете участь у політиці
Але він вас своїм опонентом вважає
Так чому він вас вважає свої опонентом?
Ну, я ж вам сказав. Тому що у нас з ним різні
світоглядні підходи до того
що таке, наприклад, демократія, свобода слова
Наприклад, Порошенко, для того, щоб вдруге обратися президентом
повинен ... у нього така ідея-фікс, він повинен повністю контролювати всі канали
Ну, як у нашого північно-східного сусіда.
Ви ж знаєте, так? Там теж колись були всі приватні телеканали
Вони належали олігархам, так
Олігархам, так. Неважливо, приватним особам
Ну, і тому висловлювали різну точку зору
Якщо згадати 98-й рік, то одні підтримували Примакова з Лужковим
а інші підтримували Єльцина з Путіним.
Або з кимось іще, зі Степашиним
Ось це і є демократія
Тобто, демократія - це влада олігархів?
Ні, демократія - це коли різні засоби масової інформації висловлюють різні точки зору
А сьогодні, якщо подивитися російське телебачення
годі й клацати. НТВ, Росія, ОРТ
там все однакове. Там Соловйов, там Кисельов
На НТВ не пам'ятаю, хто там.
А в Україні все-таки - різне
Так, належать вони заможним людям
Але я не можу сказати, що Пінчук - олігарх
А хто він?
Ну, він багата людина, власник
засобів масової інформації
Коли Кучма був президентом, він був олігархом
Сьогодні він не олігарх. Наскільки мені відомо
у Пінчука там, по-моєму, один депутат
всього лише є
А у вас?
У мене більше. Які поділяють мої цінності
і які близькі мені за духом
Ну, тому що я входжу до партії "Укроп"
Від партії "Укроп", наскільки мені відомо,
8 або 9 депутатів
Знаєте, я хочу з приводу ваших світоглядних відмінностей
у мене завжди виникає одне питання в зв'язку ...
Я якщо олігарх, то позитивний олігарх
- Це ви сказали
- Демократичний олігарх
А такі бувають? Я не бачила ніколи
Я знаю, що бувають олігархи в опозиції,
вони тоді стають демократами
А я ніколи не був у владі, я завжди був опозицією
Ніхто мені не дорікне, що я колись був у владі
Давайте я переформулюю
Коли їх починає переслідувати влада,
вони стають демократами
На сьогоднішній день я не можу сказати,
що мене переслідує влада
У нас відбувається позиційна якась війна
але вона в межах закону...
так, є різні забаганки, ми знаємо
чого хоче Петро Олексійович
Він прогнозований у цьому плані
Він хоче "1+1" на вибори. Ось йому кров з носа потрібен "1+1"
Зрозуміла. Отримає?
Ні, нізащо
Я хотіла запитати про вибори, які відбудуться
вже в наступному році
Очевидно, що Юлія Тимошенко
має намір брати в них участь
Називають й інших кандидатів
серед них Володимира Зеленського
і Святослава Вакарчука
Володимир Зеленський
це відомий телеведучий, актор
автор сатиричного шоу "Квартал 95"
Вакарчук - лідер групи "Океан Ельзи"
Це якась, напевно, калька тих виборів,
які були в Росії
коли Ксенія Собчак стала кандидатом у президенти
Ні, це не калька.
То, розкажіть, якому з кандидатів ви симпатизуєте?
Дивіться, я ж доволі одіозна людина, так?
І я якщо скажу, що я симпатизую комусь
не факт, що ця людина обереться
Тому я нікому не хочу зробити ведмежу послугу
Але є думка, давайте я так поставлю запитання
є думка, що ви симпатизуєте
Володимиру Зеленському
Я і Вакарчуку симпатизую
Я не відкрию, скажімо, Америку, якщо скажу,
що всі хочуть нових обличь
Але, тим не менше, якщо взяти старі обличчя
я ж сказав, виходячи з моїх світоглядних розбіжностей із Порошенком
зі старих політиків я вважаю, що найбільш гідною
на сьогоднішній день є Тимошенко
І, за великим рахунком, якби не її невдалий з піар
з точки зору - вихід із в'язниці, поява на Майдані
вона, може, виграла б ще в 2014-му році
і все пішло б інакше
Знаєте, у мене до вас останнє запитання
Воно, напевно, концептуальне
-  Ось ви сказали, що ви - добрий олігарх
- Ні, я не добрий, я позитивний
Вибачте, я неправильно сформулювала
Так, ви позитивний олігарх.
Такий позитивний герой
Ну, я позитивний лише з однієї причини
Я за демократію і за свободу слова
Я вважаю, що це дві цінності,
які відрізняють будь-яку...
Зачекайте. У мене таке до вас питання
Завжди, який би ви не відкрили підручник з політичної теорії
політології, політичного управління,
завжди кажуть, що
коли олігархи контролюють країну...
що таке олігарх?
Це людина з великим капіталом ...
Це жахливо
Так, абсолютно вірно
І який впливає на політичні рішення.
І очевидно, що ви такою людиною
або були, або є й надалі
Ось ви сказали, це жахливо
Насправді, це жахливо для України,
що в Україні досі
олігархи відіграють величезну роль
в політичному житті
Окей. Я вам скажу так
Олігархія в пострадянських країнах -
це проміжний стан перед захопленням
скажімо так, всієї економічної влади
великими корпораціями
Тобто після олігархів прийдуть публічні компанії
які будуть правити країною
Припустімо, у вас в Росії публічна компанія ТНК-BP була
Там був олігарх Фрідман
А сьогодні там олігарха Фрідмана немає
Ця компанія належить BP і належить Роснефти
Роснефть - це велика корпорація. Правильно?
Чи є Сечин олігархом?
Він - керівник державної корпорації
у нього немає телебачення, у нього нічого немає.
Чи є він олігархом?
Править він країною? Чи впливає він на Путіна?
Близький до нього?
Ось, дайте відповідь на це питання
Ви знаєте, ви неправильний приклад наводите. Давайте порівняємо Україну і Німеччину
Те, що відбувається в Росії... в Росії - авторитарний режим
Де всі олігархи перейшли зі стану самостійності в стан залежності
Згоден з вами
Але просто Росія пішла по гілці історії в глухий кут
в деградацію. А могла піти в еволюцію
Олігархат - це зло для розвитку країни?
Чи це неминучість
для пострадянських країн?
Неможна на складні питання відповідати просто
Якщо олігархат або олігархічна модель є проміжною на шляху до контролю
до цивілізованого ринку, як в Німеччині або в США
коли є публічні компанії і правлять публічними компаніями
незалежні ради директорів, то це - неминучість.